ce camion
cette place est que avec cette télé
grogne j'ai la possibilité de faire
prendre toutes les voies l'arrêter il
s'en rend même pas compte
regarde pas si j'appuie peut s'arrêter
là et bien d'avoir approché toi j'ai
appuyé deux fois je peux lui faire faire
johnny reid et non c'est un truc énorme
c'est pas dit que ça marche des fois il
me fait sardou mais attends je l'appuie
johnny aura beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le
sommeil parce que ça brûle
et puis ça fait du bien la pole en a
besoin dans salut je lui achète à vue
c'est un génie ouai c'est trop bien
écoute moi je suis vert ici moi j'aime
bien la campagne
ça changera pas le chant jeunesse les
kills et issa et y retient de lui on
écoute tout seul avec les enfants avec
jal est pure loyer voire bahreïn et que
les suivent tu vois c'est ça qui est
bien c'est que c'est une espèce
d'application tout comme que tu
télécharges à la fois tu peux arrêter
les gens et en même temps leur faire
faire des imitations mais ça c'est là
c'est le haut de gamme
je suis sévère aggravé et insight c'est
vraiment c'est bon quoi